aquí tenemos una reacción de combustión
de este lado tenemos al hidrocarburo
metano reaccionando con oxígeno
molecular calentamos para que empiece la
combustión y se producirá dióxido de
carbono agua y un poco más de energía de
la que entra al inicio es una reacción
exotérmica más energía sale de la que
entra es por eso que el fuego se propaga
y que la combustión se usa como fuente
de energía
pero este vídeo no se trata sobre eso
sino más bien quiero que pensemos cuál
de estos elementos es oxidado y cuál es
reducido para eso pensemos primero en
los estados de oxidación de los
elementos que componen a los reactivos y
los estados de oxidación de los que
componen a los productos los invito a
pausar el vídeo y traten de averiguar la
respuesta por su cuenta
voy a suponer que ya lo intentaron
ahora averigüemos lo juntos pensemos
primero en el metano por aquí tenemos un
montón de electro negatividades basadas
en la escala de polling pero
visualicemos al metano el metano es un
carbono unido a cuatro hidrógenos
cuatro hidrógenos en el mundo de los
estados de oxidación tenemos que
imaginar que estos enlaces covalentes
son enlaces iónicos tenemos que darle el
par de electrones a uno de estos dos si
observamos entre el carbono y el
hidrógeno el carbono es más electro
negativo que el hidrógeno supongamos que
el carbono acapara los electrones y el
hidrógeno los deja ir entonces el
carbono en este mundo imaginario toma el
electrón de cada uno de los hidrógenos
tendrá un estado de oxidación 4 negativo
un electrón por cada uno de los 4
hidrógenos recuerden escribir el signo
después del número así no hay confusión
con los exponentes
ahora pensemos en los hidrógenos a cada
uno de los hidrógenos en este mundo les
quitan un electrón podemos decir que
tienen un estado de oxidación uno más o
simplemente escribimos el signo positivo
también tenemos oxígeno molecular un
oxígeno unido a otro oxígeno todos los
oxígenos son iguales no hay isótopos o
algo parecido en esta realidad no hay
razón para que un oxígeno acapare los
electrones del otro y cuando se
encuentra en esta forma molecular tiene
un estado de oxidación o número de
oxidación cero
ahora veamos a los productos qué pasa
con el dióxido de carbono el dióxido de
carbono es un carbono unido por dobles
enlaces a 2 oxígenos sabemos que el
oxígeno es uno de los elementos más
electro negativos definitivamente más
electro negativo que el carbono así que
en nuestro mundo iónico diríamos que el
oxígeno toma 4 electrones cada oxígeno
tomará 2 electrones del carbono el
carbono perderá sus 4 electrones eso nos
da una carga 4 positiva supongamos una
carga 4 positiva y cada uno de los
oxígenos gana 2 electrones lo que les da
una carga 2 negativa
entonces 4 positivo y 2 veces 2 negativo
es 4 negativo nos queda una molécula
neutral lo cual tiene sentido porque
estas moléculas son neutrales y
finalmente el agua ya la hemos visto
miles de veces el oxígeno que en
realidad se une a los hidrógenos con
enlaces covalentes en nuestro mundo
iónico el oxígeno es más electro
negativo así que suponemos que tomará
los electrones de los hidrógenos
entonces cada hidrógeno pierde un
electrón lo que le da un número de
oxidación de 1 positivo y el oxígeno
ganó 2 electrones
eso le da un número de oxidación 2
negativo
ahora pensemos en quién es oxidado y
quién es reducido enfoquémonos primero
en el carbono el carbono inicia con un
número de oxidación de 4 negativo y
cuando la reacción ocurre el carbono
termina con un número de oxidación 4
positivo entonces cómo puede algo ir de
un 4 negativo a un 4 positivo bueno la
forma de incrementar la carga o mejor
dicho la carga supuesta es perdiendo
electrones cada vez que se pierde un
electrón esto se vuelve menos negativo
es decir cada vez se vuelve más positivo
entonces hay que perder 8 electrones
escribiré más 8 electrones justo aquí
le quitamos 8 electrones al carbono para
obtener este lado de la reacción y esto
que les estoy escribiendo se llaman
reacciones parciales en donde nos
enfocamos a cada uno de los elementos de
la reacción de forma independiente así
que este es el carbono en esta reacción
el carbono pierde 8 electrones como le
llamamos cuando un elemento pierde
electrones bueno recordemos las palabras
de reducción es ganar electrones y
oxidación es perder electrones o también
estaba gerpe o ganar electrones es
reducción y perder electrones es
oxidación entonces está claro que el
carbono es oxidado pierde electrones y
la oxidación es perder electrones
el carbono es oxidado
ahora veamos el hidrógeno del lado
izquierdo tenemos 4 hidrógenos y del
lado derecho también hay cuatro podemos
escribirlo como 2 h 2 cada uno tiene un
número de oxidación de 1 más
los números de oxidación para los
hidrógenos no cambiaron entonces los
hidrógenos no fueron oxidados ni
reducidos ahora vamos con los oxígenos
del lado izquierdo tenemos 2 o 2 con un
número de oxidación neutral y que
tenemos del lado derecho bueno tenemos 4
oxígenos en total
simplemente escribimos 4 oxígenos cuál
es un número de oxidación bueno ya vimos
que es de 2 negativos entonces qué le
pasó a estos 4 oxígenos
aquí tenemos 4 oxígenos con el número de
oxidación neutral un número de oxidación
de 0 y de este lado tenemos 4 oxígenos
con un número de oxidación negativo como
pasamos de 0 a un número 2 negativo
bueno cada uno debe ganar 2 electrones
entonces para expresar que gana
electrones escribiré por aquí más 8
electrones
qué fue lo que le pasó al oxígeno bueno
el oxígeno ganó electrones y como le
llamamos cuando algo gana electrones
reducción es ganar red o ser ganar
electrones es reducción el oxígeno fue
reducido
ahora que óxido al carbono el carbono
perdió electrones que el oxígeno ganó
así que el carbono fue oxidado por el
oxígeno y que redujo al oxígeno bueno el
oxígeno tomó los electrones del carbono
entonces el oxígeno fue reducido por el
carbono a este tipo de reacciones donde
ocurre la oxidación y la reducción es
decir que algo es oxidado y algo es
reducido se les conoce como reacciones
óxido reducción
o también redux
que sintetiza la palabra reducción en
red y oxidación en box también se les
llama reacciones redux esta es una
reacción redox algo fue oxidado y algo
fue reducido no todo es oxidado o
reducido y lo hemos comprobado al
escribir las reacciones parcial es una
forma de revisar que las reacciones
parciales están bien es sumando las nos
debe de quedar la reacción original
menos los electrones y lo mismo para
este lado debemos tener todas las
moléculas menos los electrones entonces
si sumamos todo lo que tenemos del lado
izquierdo nos queda todo esto más 8
electrones
y al sumar todo el lado izquierdo nos
queda esto más 8 electrones también al
final los 8 electrones de ambos lados se
cancelan y nos queda la reacción
original aquí lo dejamos por ahora en
química esta es una herramienta muy
poderosa realmente nos ayuda a pensar en
lo que está ocurriendo en una reacción